[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and we have the brand
new chapter of the attack on Titan manga
out right now that's right chapter 96 is
out and in this chapter we finally get
the full story of how it all began from
the perspectives of Reiner bertolt and
Annie we also get some other really
interesting little details that could
end up playing an extremely important
role in the future so let's get into it
if you enjoy these chapter views I want
to see more in the future be sure to
smash that like button strong enough to
break wall Maria and if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell we begin right
after Marcel is eaten by Amir's Titan
and the warriors from our lay lose the
job Titan power on Paradise Island
Reiner blames himself and struggles to
get his bearings as his mind seems to
have gone blank however any and bertolt
soon catch up to him and we realized
that right after Marcel was eaten the
other warriors ran away
anny blames Reiner and Bertold for
running away first because she says that
she was swept up in it and then she ran
away with them too and here it seems
that she clearly doesn't want to admit
that she was also scared Annie says that
if they didn't run away they may have
been able to retrieve the job hiding
after it turned back into a human but
now they lost the job packing power and
the mission will be seen as a complete
failure by the Malayan government we
also learned that Titans should not have
been so far away from the wall which
leads us to believe that the Emir's
mindless titan was an abnormal
tightening in some way Bertolt and Annie
consider abandoning the mission to
capture the founding Titan in order to
try and retrieve the JA titan power but
Reiner not wanting to disappoint his
mother warns them that if they return
without completing the mission they may
all be killed as punishment and their
power may be given back to the other
warriors instead Reiner also says that
the only way to catch up to the jaw
Titan if the new possessor decides to
use it is with the cart Titan or cart
man and of course Peaks
Titan is not there with them at the time
and this implies that cart man may
actually be the fastest Titan
after after Reiner speech any freaks out
and beats the crap out of him saying
that she must return home alive and this
is why the writers personality seems to
[ __ ] he gets up and jumps on a knee
putting her in a chokehold he says that
now that they've lost their leader
Marcel he will step up and become the
numerous cell the new leader and he will
make sure that they all get back home
alive
we then jump to Annie's female Titan
running towards the wall and attracting
the other - Titans to follow them
because their plan is to break the wall
bring the mindless Titans inside and
blend in with the civilian population in
the ensuing chaos after blending in with
the local population their mission is to
observe the Fritz family and find the
founding Titan Reiner in his armored
Titan form shields unexhausted Annie as
bertolt turns into the Colossus Titan
and breaks through the gate of wall
Maria we even get a glimpse of Aaron
Armin and Mikasa looking on in terror as
the Colossus titan breaks the gate and I
thought that this was a powerful image
because we now see this iconic first
scene in the manga and the anime from
the other perspective from the
perspective of the attackers as Bertold
breaks through the gate we see once
again a familiar smiling face the
smiling Titan returns once more the
smiling Titan closes in on Bertold who
is now again in his human form and
everyone thinks that the smiling Titan
is about to eat him but instead of doing
that the smiling Titan walks right past
him and through the now open gate of the
wall demonstrating again that it is an
abnormal Titan and that it seemed to be
on some sort of mission of its own now
this is really intriguing I wonder if
the smiling Titan because she is of
course Vina Yeager grisha's first wife
was able to sense grisha's blood his son
Aaron was somewhere nearby and went
straight to him instinctively this
raises a whole new question can Titans
with royal blood actually sent other LD
ins or maybe LD ins that they are close
to we know that Deena told Grisha that
she would find him someday even if they
turn her into a Titan and we know that
the cordon
connect all ldiots through invisible
pathways so I wonder if the smiling
Titan was actually able to sense where
grisha's blood was where his family his
son was if this is the case then can
weak
also sense where Aaron is if so this
could play a major role in the coming
chapters since we know that Zeek is
planning to return two parodies and we
also know that in chapter 83 he promised
to one day save Aaron
whatever that means at this point Reiner
once again remembers his mother and how
she believes that his father would be
proud of him
even though his father didn't want
anything to do with him he remembers
that he was never supposed to be chosen
as a warrior but he commits himself
again to becoming a true warrior in
spite of everything
we then jump to the refugee camp inside
of all roles where Annie Berthold and
Reiner were able to infiltrate
pretending to be part of the local
population we see a man telling them
about being the only survivor of the
Titan attack in a small mountain village
and in the very next scene we see that
man hanging from a tree as if he
committed suicide but we know of course
that the Warriors killed him and made it
look like suicide so that they can take
his backstory of being from the small
mountain village where no one else
survived and used it to infiltrate the
society within the walls then we move to
another scene and two years have now
passed the Warriors are talking about
the fritzsche royal family and how the
current royal family is actually fake
the real royal family is in hiding and
there is no way to infiltrate their
ranks because they became extremely
cautious after Wall Maria was breached
and they stopped hiring outsiders the
warriors decide that the only way to get
closer to the royal family is to join
the military as soldiers and eventually
gain posts in the capital as part of the
Military Police Brigade from the
discussion between Annie bertolt and
Reiner we also learned another really
interesting piece of information the
tiber family was the one that told them
our layin army that the king is tied
down by the promise of pacifism and that
he wouldn't use the Titan power the
founding Titan power to attack Marlay
even if the walls were breached this
makes me wonder whether the Tiber family
has spies inside the walls who are
giving them this information and whether
those spies are still alive and active
in the
and time working behind the backs of
Levi's Aaron Armand and the rest of our
protagonist also in this scene we
clearly see that bertolt totally has a
thing for any and the chapter ends on a
very interesting note we see that from
the perspective of the Warriors they
believe that they are trying to save
humanity they believe that by taking the
founding Titan power they will make sure
that the LD isn't parodies cannot use
the wall Titans to wipe out humanity on
the continent including the families of
the LLVM warriors themselves when they
are asked by Charlotte's the head
instructor of the 104th Training Corps
what they all came here for why they
decided to become soldiers Reiner
responds I came here to save humanity
and he really means this but in a
totally different ways and the LD ends
on the island could have imagined at the
time overall I thought that this was a
really really interesting chapter we see
how it all began but from the opposite
perspective how we see how the warriors
despite all the horrible things they did
to innocent elding's on the island are
doing what they're doing because they
believe that they are saving humanity
they believe that the LD and on the
island are evil they are afraid of the
founding type of power and they want to
protect their own families and humanity
on the continent by fighting against the
LD end on the island
we also learned in this chapter that
Amir's mindless titan and the smiling
titan were indeed abnormals
and the smiling Titan may have been able
to somehow sense where grisha's blood
was his bloodline his son Aaron even
though we think that Grisha at this
point was somewhere out of town by the
way guys if you want to learn more about
the smiling Titan all the backstory of
Deana Yeager and how she became the
smiling Titan you can check out our
video smiling Titan explained I will
leave the link in the description on top
of that we have videos in our attack on
Titan playlist explaining the female
Titan and Annie their whole back story
explaining Amir and her jaw Titan
explaining a Reiner and his backstory
and everything about him as well as the
Colossus Titan and bertolt if it's been
a while since you've read the previous
chapters of the manga and you want to
catch up on all the relevant details
feel free to check out those videos as
well links will be in the description
finally we learned that the Tiber family
may have spies inside the walls perhaps
very close to the royal family itself
which itself is a huge revelation that
might come into play in the present time
so yeah even though we didn't get to see
our protagonists on the island in the
present this was a really captivating
really powerful chapter in my opinion
let me know what you think down below
let me know what you think about the
smiling Titan and the way it just went
past Bertolt and seemed to be going
after Aaron let me know what you think
about the Tiber family having spies and
in general what you think about this
chapter and what do you think is going
to happen in the next chapter I'm really
excited
of course do you think that in the next
chapter we are finally going to see Myka
saw Aaron arm and Levi and the rest our
protagonist in the present timeline
again let me know thank you guys so much
for watching if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell for more videos
and until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]